It's an eyesore, damn it, kid, it's unreasonable Still
pushing forward alone To
win against others An
existence that can't be read It's
a one-or-done last piece What I have to eat is that I wo
n't buy it The
freestyle that I was about to forget
Everyone is also with the ball  I wish I could be with you
Then you can play great
There's nothing more fun than soccer
Yes,
even being alone is just
fun and chasing the ball until the sun goes down
Like those days when I was
one with the ball  It's enough for me to
play soccer with everything I have There's nothing
in this world that's more fun for me Even if I'm
ridiculed for being strange Even if I'm all alone I
don't have any friends What should I
do?
Passion is mine  It's not you inside I'm the
monster
Thank you for
staying with me until now It's
fun even if you're no one But
from now on
[music] is
bye-bye
[Applause]
You've played football with me all this time  Isagi
[music]
Unleash the lonely soccer
[music] It's the
ego that started
Hurry up, I
believed you'd come here alone